somebody asked me the other day if I
believed in miracles and I hate being
asked questions like that you know and
you know it's also people ask me do I
believe in God and like I don't know
what they mean when they say that so I
don't know what to answer because I
don't think we're talking necessarily
going to talk about the same thing but
in any case I said yes and I have a
variety of reasons for that but one of
them is that you know the consensus
among physicists is that we can track
the origin of the cosmos to something
like a hundred millionth of a millionth
of a second after the Big Bang it's like
it's so close to the Big Bang that the
difference is literally infinitesimal
but the consensus is that before that
whatever that is the laws of physics
themselves break down well what what do
you call an event that exists outside
the laws of physics that by definition
that's a miracle now that doesn't
necessarily mean that there's a
transcendent Adi that caused the event
that's a separate issue but it does
imply a barrier of some sort beyond
which we can't go where some other set
of rules apply and so I find that
interesting as well